one day
15 years ago everything changed
[Music]
you was covered in this woo someone dumb
in the source whatever the screws was it
transformed us
it was weird but we became a family
[Music]
boys Where Have You Been
we're just running errands that's it
oh look we're really sorry Spooner some
of the guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to talk him out of it yeah you
ratted us out hey don't use that word
that way I mean it's 20 25.
oh
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we pick out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dog
my son Michelangelo you have heart
Donatello you have wisdom Raphael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage it's not a
problem
right